let's go next to our caller from the 831
area code caller from 831 what's your
name where are you calling from
hey this is Phil from California hey
Phil what's up hey so uh recently New
York decided to spend the primaries and
the last couple of weeks
people have been researching into the
exit poll discrepancies between Super
Tuesday and some other states do you
have a lot of faith in the elections
these days and how confident are you and
your vote being applied accurately in
November well so there's two kind of the
the latter question is an easy one I'm
pretty confident my vote will be applied
accurately in November that's my belief
based on what I observe voting here in
Massachusetts in Prior elections but
that's the more important question
you're asking is the first one which is
general confidence in the election
system I mean listen there's no doubt
that there is one party that has been
working for 15 to 20 years to try to
suppress the vote and or or to
disenfranchise and this includes
everything from redistricting and
gerrymandering up through and including
voter ID voter purges etc right now -
based on what's going on right now my
instinct is that 2020 november 2020 is
not going to be as determined by maybe
voting machines as has been the focus in
the past but how people are interacting
with the voting system in general
meaning vote in person versus vote by
mail and how coronavirus is going to
affect turnout so because that is
unprecedented and crazy and we see one
side democrats saying we should be
voting by mail you see trump saying we
should not be voting by mail that is
making me scared about what is going to
happen in November of 2020 now all the
other things like voter ID everything
that that those are all still issues but
for me what's most present and foremost
of for most importance for November is
where are people going to vote how are
people going to vote and
how is that all going to be carried out
because we know Trump knows vote-by-mail
is bad for him yeah true
and I was also I had a lot of I have a
lot of Bernie friends that you know what
the earlier caller was talking about the
never Biden thing yep they've discussed
it I think most people are going to
actually vote for Biden because they
kind of are going to do the math and but
they're got two plus years before for
them most people are a lot of in just
real quick in 2016 I think you had about
a 10% of Bernie supporters ended up
voting for Hillary and that's a sorry
ended up voting for Trump and they're
voting for Trump 10% of Bernie
supporters voted for Trump
that's roughly in line with what we see
in terms of abandonment in Prior
elections like there was not a crazy
number of amount of that in 2016
yeah well and Hillary's supporters voted
for McCain more than Bernie supporters
voted for Trump yep but I just think
it's one of those things where the
Democratic Party had a real chance to
ignite a base and they may have just
created more independence and more
people that just don't feel you know
like the party represents them anymore
because frankly the whole dole campaign
just felt like a smear you know
everything on the media it was just so
negative so I think a lot of people just
have a bad taste in their mouth and
voting for Biden's not gonna help them
we will see where where it all shakes
out I think that there's a there's a
there's a universe where you are correct
but Biden still wins right I mean the
number you could be right and Biden
still could get the votes he needs to
become president we've got six months to
go and a lot can happen between now and
then yeah I would put a lot of pressure
on Biden to make our things happen if we
wanted to so that's better with them
Trump yeah thank you appreciate the call
thank you so much